e
Davide Gentile est allé voir
comment on se débrouille et se
prépare au t d d des fêtes.
- C'est une des urgences
les plus surchargées au Québec.
Dre ANDRÉA CHABOT NAUD
urgentologue, Hôpital du Suroît
- En ce moment on a 50 patients
couchés sur civière. Donc,
on est à 160 % d'occupation.
- Ici le taux d'occupation
des civières dépasse
régulièrement les 200 %.
Et la fin espérée de la pandémie
n'apporte aucun répit
aux employés.
NATASHA LAMONTAGNE, infirmière
à l'urgence, Hôpital du Suroît
- Les gens ne portent plus leur
masques pour aller à'é'é'épicer,
mais nous, tu sais, la vie n'a
pas changé pour nous, ici.
- Quelques minutes après notre
arrivée, l'équipe de l'urgence
se déploie pouerererer de sauver
un aîné.
JESSICA SAUVÉ, infirmière
à l'urgence, Hôpital du Suroît
- Influenza, virus respiratoire,
tout ç s s s sont là et je pense
même pire qu'avant et pour
certains, les symptômes sont
pires que la COVID.
- Partout, des enfants frappés
pavivivivirus d'hiver.
- On est allés à Chateauguay
l'autre jour, il y avait
30 heures d'attente, fait que
c'est pour ça qu'on vientititit.
- Le plus gros problème,
c'est encore et toujours
le manque de personnel.
LINE DAOUST, dir. prog. soins
crit., CISSS Montérégie-Ouest
- On est en situation difficile.
On est à peu près à 50 %
de nos personnes en place.
- La moitié des postes ne sont
pas comblés et l'Hôpital n'a
que la moitié des lits dont
il aurait besoin.
- Au Québec, la moyenne,
c'est deux lits par 1000
habitants. Des lits de soins
aigus. Ici, je suis à un,
j'ai un lit par 1000.
- Mais le CISSS de Montérégie-
Ouest se démène pour éviter
l'asphyxie. Un département
d'hospitalisation a fermé
pour agrandir l'urgence.
Faute d'espace suffisant
le défi est surtout de permettre
aux patients de retourner
rapidement à domicile
pour libérer des lits.
Dr MITCHELL GERMAIN, chef,
départ. méd. CISSS Montérégie
- On a pu trouver des médecins
qui ont levé la main pour
prendre en charge des patients
dans les soins à domicile.
Mais c'est clair et certain que
ça va être la voie qu'on doit
prioriser; l'hospitalisation
à maison.
- You have pain when I touch?
- L'établissement innove,
le personnel travaille, de plus
en plus. Mais les hôpitaux de
l'ouest de la Montérégie luttent
à contre-courant.
- On s'améliore partout, mais on
est tellement r r r r r r cette
population-là, qui est
disproportionné par rapport
à notre capacité, que c'est
comme si tous nos résultats sont
masqués.
- L'aîné secouru au début
de notre visite a été sauvé.
Une petite vicseseseseseserait
impossible sans le temps
supplémentaire qui ici,
est presque la norme.
- On tient le coup, je pense
qu'on est une super de belle
équipe et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on reste, en fait.
Parce qu'on a quand même pensé à
quitter le navire quelques fois,
mais on est une belle équipe.
- Le personnel espère que
les rassemblements de Noël
ne provoqueront pas d'afflux
de patients grippés.
Parce que leur seul véritable
répit viendra avec
l'inauguration d'un nouvel
hôpital dans la région, en 2026.
Ici Davide Gentil